so the question was asked favorite books  um i wish i could fill this out a little  bit better  it's been a long time since i've sat  down to read something if i'm being  completely honest  but my all-time favorite book goes back  and forth  between the last unicorn by peter s  beagle  and restaurant at the end of the  universe by douglas adams  i know most people go for hitchhiker's  guides at the galaxy i just find  restaurant at the end of the universe  more  satisfying and kind of complete and also  it has some of my absolutely favorite  scenes with my favorite character from  that  which is they fought bible procs now  when it comes to the last unicorn  that is that was so beautifully written  that it made me angry  like i would have to stop between  chapters and be like it's not fair that  somebody  wrote something this gorgeous it's just  not fair the rest of us  so those easily compete for my top two  and there have been others along the way  but  those are the two big ones